as an aspiring entrepreneur there are a
number of terms that you'll need to be
intimately familiar with throughout the
course we'll help you talk the talk of a
business owner in these short terms to
know segments we'll start with the
basics profit versus revenue now we've
already spoken a bit about the
differences between the two revenue is
the total amount of money your company
collects now profits are the most
important number for you to focus on as
an entrepreneur after all it's the only
way for your business to survive if
you're a business that maybe makes a lot
of money but maybe your expenses and
operating costs are eclipsing that you
can still go under now there are even
further distinctions between types of
profit gross and net these terms are
some of the most easily confused for
those new to the world of finance but
see if you can identify the definitions
for each of these terms just by entering
the correct letter in the boxes provided